About seven women are killed in Mexico every day.
Over the last seven years, 8,900 women were murdered in Mexico.
And less than a third of those cases were properly investigated as femicides,
or the killing of women because of their gender.
The latest case to spark outrage is that of 8-year-old Ana Lizbeth Polina Ramírez.
She was abducted near her mother’s workplace in Juárez, Nuevo León.
Her body was found two days later in a vacant lot.
One single mom is trying to break the cycle of violence.
She wants to save the lives of women, including her teenage daughter.
Dayra Fyah is a mom and self-defense instructor. She is also a rapper who uses her music to stand up against gender violence.
She lives with her daughter in Ecatepec. It’s arguably one of the most dangerous places for women in Mexico.
The Mexico City suburb has one of the highest rates of killings and disappearances in the country.
Here in Ecatepec, the Mexican government has issued a gender violence alert, warning the public that women are being targeted and murdered.
Dayra doesn’t want women to be victims. So she organizes self-defense classes like this one to help them fight back.
But Dayra’s motivation to teach women how to defend themselves goes deeper.
She wants to protect her daughter Cynthia,
who has already experienced sexual harassment at a young age.
Cynthia is 14 years old. She doesn’t take public transportation by herself because of the widespread sexual harassment.
Still, Dayra doesn’t want her daughter to live in fear and is raising her to be confident and independent.
Although men dominate the hip-hop music industry, Dayra is defying gender roles and making a name for herself.
She is currently recording her third album.